she is a record-breaking cyclist who for
her whole life has been competing
against men but when emily bridges
publicly came out as transgender 18
months ago she longed to race in the
female category
this week the british cyclists hopes
were shattered
she was set to compete against several
british olympians including dame laura
kenny but the decision came after
backlash within the sport some
professional female riders think bridges
may have an unfair advantage
women have a protected category they
have that category so that we have
opportunities and so that we can excel
in sport
if you take that away and you allow male
bodies into that category
you you are you will destroy women's
sport
trans inclusion in top level sports has
been a contentious subject for many
years one too familiar for marathon
runner joanna who's now focused on
evaluating the effects of transition on
sporting performance
the question is
can testosterone suppression
mitigate the advantages of going through
male puberty sufficiently to allow
meaningful competition between trans
women and cis women
it's not a definitive answer at this
point
it's tests like this emily bridges has
been taking over the last year to
measure her performance after reducing
testosterone levels but despite passing
the criteria she's still being blocked
from competing a move which has brought
anger across the trans community
like here in east london where history
has been made
natalie is taking part in the world's
first football match consisting of
solely transgender women but she feels
their achievements have been
overshadowed
it's sad that we've lost an opportunity
to have someone really kind of break new
ground for us and to really kind of give
the community something positive to
shout about at a time when we haven't
had a lot of things to be really
positive about and the community's under
what feels like a real attack actually
british cycling have said emily bridger
is disappointed and that now is the time
for a coalition to address trans
participation in elite sports but she is
an athlete who was set to shine in this
year's commonwealth games
moments which may now not be possible in
zaman rashid sky news love bro